[Music]
so this talk is about studied typing
which is a less data science and less
platonic probably than our than usual
but nevertheless is something found
useful in the process of building data
products for the nice to meet you slide
I also put the PI data London logo in
case you didn't notice the high
visibility t-shirt and one of the
organizers in fact and maybe you notice
also the little posters around about the
book signing that was also introduced in
the the opening notes so I'll be do
designing I have a few free copies of my
book on social media mining and also
some discount codes if the something
you're interested in we also have ian
having a few copies of his book on high
performance computing and rebecca with a
book on natural language processing so
that will be interesting and recently i
also been working again with my
publisher back publishing and we
released a series of videos on a date
analysis with python ok now back back on
topic the starting point is essentially
every conversation I ever have with the
developers who are not coming from a
Python background we always end up
discussing you know pros and cons of the
languages and the bottom line is Python
is really tight well not really the
correct statement is that Python is
strongly typed but the source of the
confusion is coming from the fact that
Python is also dynamically typed so this
will be a bit of a slow introduction to
Python typing before we move on to to
the static type in oceans so what we
mean by strong and dynamic so we do have
data types so in this example we have a
simply an integer but there is no need
to declare it so the interpreter is
inferring the datatype
dynamically and we also have type errors
so some operations like salmon string
tuning that tune integers are not
allowed so the interpreter will raise a
type error in this case the nature of
the dynamic nature of a Python anyway
sometimes leads to some kind of what the
hell moment so that's when the
developers coming from a static
background they start cringing so you
can mix up sometimes the types in this
example bully ants are treated as
integers that's because boolean
effectively are subsets of int in Python
this all documented when you're new to
Python may be surprising so you can sum
a boolean with to an integer you can
multiply an integer with a boolean and
so on any terms of a type errors back to
the to the previous example sometimes
some operations are allowed like you can
multiply string times number and that's
string concatenation and others are not
allowed so that we raise a type error so
this is a bit confusing sometimes now in
Python does this notion of duck typing
which is a basically small like a
mindset if you want I think the term was
originally coined by Alex Martel a few
years back and I'm not sure there's a
formal definition so this is what I
found out essentially that's what you
usually find on the web on Wikipedia and
so on so duck typing he looks like a
duck she swims like a duck if it quacks
like a duck then probably it is a duck
so in short if it quacks it's a duck to
better understand the the idea of duck
typing we can compare the two different
mindset or principles and they both have
a fancy acronym but really the ideas
behind them are are really simple so the
first one e a f p1 mostly adopted in
Python most pythonic if you want so it's
coming from this idea this notion
that Caesar to ask forgiveness than it
is to get permission Grace Hopper was
the lady who brought the first compiler
and she did so many other things and she
also inspire the generations of computer
scientists so it's easier to ask
forgiveness than it is to get permission
on the other side the opposite principle
is then to ask for permission first and
also we have another fancier canary this
is also called look before you leap
look before your lip means we are
testing the preconditions before making
our calls and I just want to give you an
example of look before you leap first so
say you want to call your your duck you
want to make it quack
so first you check if the object
supports the particular operation you
check that the object duck has been a
total quack and then you call duck walk
that's all right
but what's happening here is that you're
accessing the the object twice first to
check if the method is there and then to
actually call the method and back to our
asking for forgiveness so the pythonic
way of doing things we don't check first
we just try to call directly the the
method and if something goes wrong we
capture the exception and then we deal
with it
now if you if you've been doing this
approach for a while maybe you notice is
not the perfect way of doing things you
shouldn't capture any exception you
should make sure that you capture only
the specific exception so a better way
of doing it would be capture the
attribute error meaning the duck object
does not have the quack attribute or
maybe capture type error if you want
anyway make sure that you capture the
correct exception now wrapping
everything up with this notion of asking
forgiveness and duck typing it also
means if we have an object which is not
a duck say it's a dog but if the dog
can't walk we don't care scoot enough
for us still attack from our point of
view
so that's the idea of duck type we don't
focus on the what the object is we focus
on the behavior we focus on what the
object can do and how we can use it so
we focus on the interface and on the
behavior and this is all the interesting
makes for good philosophical
conversation after a few pints it's not
only philosophical so so it has some
practical implications here so that's an
important questions that we should think
about how many type related errors we
can catch before runtime that's an
important point in static versus dynamic
typing so often people put the put
languages in two different classes so
it's really a binary classification
static versus dynamic but really it's a
bit more like a continuum so different
languages behave in different ways right
so it's not always clear stopping versus
dynamic for example JavaScript with the
one plus one example from earlier
strings and integers the result would be
the string 11 so this sum between string
and integers is allowed in JavaScript
now I'm not saying javascript is more
dynamic than Python I'm saying they just
behave differently and then of course
you can put a kind of a scale of the
chart you can put Scala somewhere in
between so Scala is statically typed but
also the compiler has some capabilities
to do type inference so that the social
dynamic aspect in it
there's not really a binary
classification that's one way of looking
at things but then usually people anyway
are very very polarized so they go they
really like the binary classification so
this life should be benefits of dynamic
typing but the attitude of the world
always is like dynamic typing leave me
alone so the benefit of dynamic typing
mainly flexibility so you don't have the
constraints of static typing and
looking at the language and the Python
is particularly good here it's less
verbose so you have less code to write
essentially you don't bother about the
static typing and the feeling overall is
that you write code faster the opposite
direction so benefits of static typing
and again the attitude is how can you
dealer how can you live without it it's
about catching arrows before runtime so
the compiler does the job for you often
of catching some of the silly mistakes
that you do because you don't check
properly for you don't capture the right
exception or don't check for the correct
type and so on also static typing has
the benefit of being a kind of a inline
documentation because you declare your
function definition so you know what
kind of attributes sorry what kind of
arguments you're expecting what kind of
a type you're giving back and so on
also this better support for your
editors you can have support for work
and well to complete and stuff like that
also with dynamic typing but in static
typing you have adjust better better
support here and finally static typing
also allows to allow the compiler to do
some optimization and I put it in
bracket because it don't really what we
do in Python so it's a kind of a generic
benefit of static typing when it's not
it's not happening in Python so we can
we can cross it out okay I've tried to
kind of balance a few benefits on both
side dynamic and Static and now I just
want to discuss some extra problems or
little issues that we have so we need
the work up is not a problem that I have
is a Wragby scram from an outsider point
of view it looks very messy but then if
you are like with a row if you know
about right but you know that basically
everybody has a precise role they know
how to bind and know where to push when
to push so they clearly know what
they're doing that's kind of like a data
science team
from an outsider point of view what are
these data scientists doing but then
from an insider we always know what they
were doing right do we okay so with
these little problems they want to
mention so teams are changing they're
growing some turnover so you have new
people coming in if you hire them is
because they know what they're doing
probably but then they don't really know
they're not familiar with the codebase
they're not familiar with the process so
it takes time to get people up to speed
refactoring is also something that
nobody really likes but as part of the
job so you fix something on one side and
then you break something some rails
documentation so this poor right it's
never enough
and finally testing unit testing you
know you should be realistic and kind of
honest with yourself
we don't write enough unit tests that's
a hard reality and I would argue with
all these little problems kind of a
they're part of the long-term process of
building stable solid robust products
and here the edges are a bit in favor of
static typing so static typing something
that helps in doesn't solve all these
problems but it's a tool that helps
tackling all these problems so what's
going on with Python with Python since
python 3.0 so we're talking about more
than 10 years ago we have this notion of
function annotations and they just give
you an example function notation so you
have your function definition this one
takes a couple of arguments a and B and
you can declare the expected datatype
for the arguments in this case two
integers and then with the little arrow
thing you can also declare the return
type of the function which is a string
in this example
annotations are really ignored by the
interpreter so this like a syntax
support syntax is legal but the
interpreter is not doing anything about
it then more recently Python 3.5 we have
this notion of type hint things so the
typing module has been introduced in
Python 3.5 and that's what makes the
typing system a bit more semantically
clear and so we have a lot of absolute
datatypes declared in the typing module
and again annotations are really ignored
by the interpreter so what's going on in
practice we have support for the syntax
we have support for the semantics but
the interpreter is ignoring the type
annotations so in practice you need an
external tool to perform static analysis
and for python we have this tool called
my pi is the Gita page of my PI optional
static static typing for Python so how
to go with it you just install it with
peepin store my PI and then it's a
command-line tool you just run it my PI
followed by the screen name or the
folder where you have your your package
or your program in general so I want to
give you a slightly more detailed
example here so you have this abstract
data types in the typing module at least
and addiction in this example and notice
the uppercase L n D so we have list and
dictionary all lowercase as kind of
built-in data type in Python but we also
have this abstract data type declared in
the typing module and if you notice so
here this function is taking an integer
as input and giving Bekaa dictionary if
you notice the B variable is also the
clear using a an inline comment as a
list of integer so the observed data
type from the typing module allow for
indexing okay so you can declare this a
list it's not only a list is a list of
integers so you can really have a better
granularity while using the D
for building datatype you cannot do this
kind of indexing now we are declaring
the function as returning a dictionary
and we are really returning a list
that's what's happening in this piece of
code so once you run my pie what happens
is that you're going to have a an arrow
raised so incompatible return value type
you are expecting a dictionary and
you're giving back a list so that's a
let's overall idea of my pie so the
interpreter will still run the code but
the mypie tool for for static analysis
will give you the error if you do this
analysis checking the error messages I
also want to point out the dictionary is
given as any-to-any
we didn't declare anything about the
dictionary so by default the dictionary
is about anything essentially and this
opens for the next concept which is
gradual typing gradual typing basically
means that we don't go from dynamic to
static overnight we do it gradually and
the any data type is something that
reduces friction so sometimes you're not
really sure about your code base you
need to kind of check what's going on so
you can place any data type and then you
can refine it later on and this is part
of a process of going to iterations to
kind of have a better understanding of
your codebase and slowly other
additional types to your code so we
mentioned lists dictionary type a nice
you just want to quickly go through a
few of these supported types so from the
type of module you can get list
dictionary tuples and so on then you
have some orphan settings iterable
objects these are all indexable so you
can also specify what they contain and
then you have optional kind of data
types the meaning should be should be
clear you have unions when a function
can take arguments of different types
and you can make a union and then the
any data type that we already mentioned
and I will we have many more on top of
this you can of course still use all the
built-in data types and also your custom
objects in terms of Python requirements
so the typing module has been introduced
in Python 3.5 so if you want to take
advantage of it you need item 3.5 you
can use any 3.3 plus to run my PI and
you can even do annotations if you have
a code base in Python 2 in this case the
annotation have to be as inline comments
rather than using the functional
notation syntax here the issue would be
you still need my PI to run the analysis
so the idea is you kind of integrate my
PI with your build server running Python
3 to do the static checking on your
Python 2 code base but you can still do
it anyway so when do you do the static
checking well you can run it from the
command line so you know as many time as
you want what I like to do usually when
things become a little bit more stable I
try to kind of wrap it up into a shell
script that can be integrated in your
build server your CI server and I tend
to group everything together with the
linker to do some extra static checking
if you don't use a flake 8 or pilant or
any other linker check them out they
help you to catch some of the easy to
spot mistakes that maybe you don't
notice in a bigger codebase and then of
course unit testing because we are all
writing unit testing unit tests and you
can run with an ulcer with PI tests with
whatever you like coverage there are
many options and then finally the static
type analysis with my PI so if you
integrate it with your build server is
it going to slow me down fair question
and I was going to talk about caching
and all the stuff the short answer is no
it's not slow it's fast enough
probably your unit tests are going to be
slower than a static analysis
what's going on with the third-party
libraries that's a bit of a pain so you
still need to kind of in understand the
interfaces of the libraries so there's
an ongoing effort of writing all the
interfaces for the most common Python
libraries so these are already part of
my PI for example request and L XML and
a few other libraries are already there
otherwise you need to sort of right at
the interface definition and put it in a
py I Python interface stop file so this
top file they only contain the
interfaces they don't contain the actual
behavior and they are used by my PI to
understand how to deal with the some
custom data types another option
ignore the third-party libraries
sometimes is just a way to to go if you
don't want to get stuck if you are in
this process of doing a gradual typing
that's where you start so you say we
follow the imports but then we silence
the errors and then there are probably
50 plus options for for my type so my PI
so you can check them out about the
errors you can skip them you can report
them you can do whatever you like
okay so start to type in really sort of
clashes with the notion of duck typing
on one side you you want to focus on
behavior rather than identity and the
precise data type on the other side I'm
saying static typing is kind of helpful
in these little problems and the idea is
ax is the last stock image I promise
the idea is a yeah
there's no freelance free lunch so you
need to find the balance is through that
static typing and duck typing are
probably clashing is through that static
typing sometimes doesn't feel very
pythonic so if you are heavily invested
in python you might find it a bit
awkward at first and all in all
not I'm not really advocating study
typing or not a big fan of static typing
something that I found useful anyway and
especially when you're kind of
graduating from doing little prototypes
towards building mature and solid
product so in this three particular
bullet points I'm I'm just summarizing
what I think static typing is most
useful so going from prototype to
amateur robust data product
understanding your code base and also in
particular when you have heterogeneous
teams new people coming in not everybody
is coming from a Python background okay
one of my last job so I was working with
c-sharp developers and we're catching up
quite quickly because we introduced
these these static types in some of our
libraries so that's really helpful when
you have people coming from different
backgrounds and maybe they like static
types so you kind of head them out okay
so this is for you for me I believe we
have a few minutes for for questions I'd
be any way around today in tomorrow
should be easy to find and it should be
easy to find online as well yeah that's
it for me thank you
[Applause]
working we like using this laterally
production time I don't know if I worked
in high spirited front-end development
one of the biggest criticism in
typescript is that we start writing your
own sides and well then you need to
attach definitely typed or like using
libraries 30 languages that are not
tight so you end up writing a lot of any
any any onion and that's basically okay
so in terms of what kind of projects
machine learning projects data pipelines
so we're thus mix of data engineering
and data science and especially things
that are kind of becoming mature so up
for the early days of your prototypes
not really useful it's probably getting
in the way and then later on when things
are more stable you kind of look at the
build server and you notice that the
last 30 problems were about some some
type error or not being properly handled
that's when things are useful but you
absolutely suck it down are kind of
models data pipelines and so on and in
terms of this friction that you
mentioned so in typescript I don't know
typescript but it's the same notion from
from what you describe so the question
is a if I use a lot of any and gradual
typing it kind of defeats the purpose of
using a static typing yes I agree it's a
it's not an overnight process and it's
not an overnight success either so you
can need to follow the this idea of
gradual typing so you slowly improve
your understanding of your huge code
base I'm assuming this a big code base
and there's a mature product to build
rather than simple scripts
three times you import library you
actually yes
so with third-party libraries I agree
that it's a bit of a pain and there's an
ongoing effort in building this type
shed so some of it is already part of my
PI for a few basic Python libraries and
then for some of the library this tenure
here working for McNally's they have
been open sourcing something with numpy
so if you're using Empire you can check
out this third-party so there are few
companies putting some effort into it
and things are getting better slowly so
this static type in notion that really
kicked off less than two years ago I
would say and I still still improving I
agree that it's not perfect I'm just
saying it's like an extra tool for you
yes like right before you merge a branch
into master just to make sure it's not
gonna melt down so is it analogous for
you like what are you you know at what
point are you kind of running my fire
okay so about the overall process
workflow kind of similar so the script
that I showed is a nobly simplified
version of what I usually do I put
together some linking for the obvious
irken style little errors and also
capturing a few things like undeclared
names and so on I put together unit
tests and I put together my PI and is
going to be wild up with your build
server depending on on what I'm doing
the pending on if it's like a moment of
heavy development or sever I might run
it more often locally and then I push a
little bit left of often so I can commit
locally and then
push once I'm a bit more confident it's
really something that sees it to
integrate in the workflow if you wire it
up with with your build server and it
goes together with with a linter in my
opinion because linting is also about
static analysis not static type analysis
but also anyway static analysis so yeah
it's um it's not coming up in the early
days of the other project while the unit
tests are coming up for for me from day
one so I and to add it a little bit data
but yeah
any other question yeah so the do I know
any IDE the truth is I don't really use
ID I like very lightweight editor and
then I do my own shell scripts and then
depending on the team I'm working with I
kind of follow what they're doing so if
they ever a Jenkins server that's what I
use if they rather stand aside as a
freelance I I kind of try to adopt what
other team is doing and and see how we
can reduce the friction for me I like
lightweight editors yeah I guess should
talk with the check trainer guys yeah
absolutely
looks like Adam have something I'm not
sure how good it is so I think that's
there's an ongoing effort also in a
bringing these new notions of static
typing into the the tools that are
commonly used
so PyCharm absolutely they were already
doing something using the inline
comments I didn't feel like it was a
sometimes for me it was a bit awkward
but maybe just me yeah things are also
improving sublime autumn apparently any
other question
[Applause]
[Music]